So I want to tell you about a letter
I got a little while ago that I only
just got around to reading.
Actually it was in 2003 that it arrived
but I only just found it on the floor; my
study is very messy.
So the author is a contributor to the
OEIS,
a former contributor, I have-
think I have to say,
called Claude Lenormand. He suggested two
transformations of sequences;
his second transformation that
introduced a word
I didn't know - a French word - called
a rabot. This is a rabot,
a plan- a carpenter's plane. And his
transformation
is to take a sequence or a word,
a string of numbers, and plane them
down,
raboter, planing the sequence.
What you plane down are the runs in a
sequence.
If we have a sequence you might be
tossing a coin and you might get heads,
heads, tails, tails, tails, heads,
tails. You look at the runs - here we've
got a run of two heads,
so we get a two. We write down the length
of the runs -
3, 1, 1 - so the runs transformation
of a string, a sequence, is the lengths of
the runs,
that's the runs transformation. What the
the plane does
it shortens all the runs by one, by one
turn.
So if we had a run of three things, in
the transform
thing we've got a run of two things so
we shorten all the runs,
that's the operation of raboter. So you
remember in one of the
earlier Numberphile videos you did, you
mentioned
a sequence of my old friend Sol Golomb.
And this is distinguished by the fact that
it's a sequence of numbers. It's the-
has the property that there- it's an
increasing, I should say non-decreasing,
sequence, it keeps
growing and it has the property
that if you look at the runs length you
get the same sequence.
All right I'll just do a couple of terms:
1, 2,
2 - how do we continue? Golomb sequence,
the 1 means the first run has length 1.
So we start off with a run of length 1,
and then we've got a run
of some other numbers. And you always
pick the smallest number
so the next number has to be a 2. That 2
says the second run has length 2
so we've got two 2s. And now that 2,
which is the third term,
says the third run
has length 2. So so yeah so it
continues 3, 3,
and then 4, 4, 4, 5, 5, 5 -
this will probably make it clearer.
So this 2 refers to those two. The
third term
is 2 and that says the third run
of successive identica
l terms has length 2.
Well okay we've got our first run, our
second run,
our third run has to have length 2. So
that means we've got two 3s.
The fourth term, and that says the next
run has length 3.
So there are going to be three 4s,
that 3 says
three 4s. This 3 says, aha,
three 5s.
- (Brady: So there'll be four 6s?)
There are gonna be four
6s! Very good. And there are going to
be four 7s
from that 4; and that 4 says there
are going to be four 8s,
and that 5 says there are going to be
five 9s.
That's the defining property. It's
non-decreasing,
you always put down the smallest number
you can,
and it must be its own runs
transformation.
So that's Golomb's sequence.
Now if we apply Le Rabot to it,
and we plane it down, what are we going
to do? Well
we're going to cross off that 1. We've
got two 2s
so we throw away one of them. We've got
two 3s we throw away one of them.
We've got three 4s we throw away one.
Five; we just
shorten all the runs - we apply
the plane, le rabot. And what we get,
the new sequence, is simply
2, 3, 4, 4, 5,
5, 6, 6, 6, 7,
7, 7 and so on. So this is the
planed down version
of Golomb's sequence. In
Claude's letter he gave the example of the
Golomb sequence and how to raboter it.
So I thought it would be very
interesting to apply
the plane, le rabot, to the numbers
to the ordinary numbers written in
binary.
Now remember the rule is when you plane
it down,
if it's got a run of length 1 it goes
away. So zero,
well, becomes zero, so we get zero.
1 goes away and we get zero.
1 goes away, zero goes away, and we get
zero. 11
becomes 1 in base
2, which is 1 in base 10. So our new
sequence
is what you get when you plane down the
numbers. So we get 000,
this is the base 2 version, this is the
base 10 version.
So 1 0 0 we lose the
1 and we shorten that zero and we get
zero.
1 0 1 - zero, base two is zero base
ten is zero.
Here now finally we get something
interesting; we lose the zero
and we lose a 1 so we get 1.
Here 1 1 1, we lose the 1, we got 1 1,
which is 1 1 which is 3. So the sequence
that we're going to
get goes 0 0 0 1 0 0 1 3.
This one we lose that
and that and we get zero; this we lose
the 1
and that and we get zero; and 10
we lose everything and
11 we lose that that and that and we
get 1.
12 we lose a 1 and a zero and
finally
we get a 2. We're doing 13, we lose
that and that and that and we get a 1.
Because 12 is 1 1 0 0 it
becomes
1 0 which is 2. 13 which is
1 1 0 1
we lose the 1 the zero and one of the
1s and all we are left with
is a 1. When we get to 14
we lose a zero and a 1 and we're left
with 1 1 which
is 3. And 1 1 1 1, which is 15,
we lose the 1, we get 1 1 1, and
we get 7. And when we get down to 16
we get zero again. So that's- and we keep
going forever.
So this is the planed down version.
This has a very nice sound, you know you
can listen to any
any of the 300,000 sequences in the OEIS
and I would like to play this sequence
for you:
(How have you turned it into music?)
- We-
imagine that we have a grand piano,
that's the basic thing, and we number the
keys 0, 1, 2, 3, up to 87 -
it's got 88 keys. We take the number
and we divide by 88 and keep the
remainder, we
reduce it mod 88. So that gives us
something we can play on the grand piano.
So if they're-
these numbers you can see are all
pretty small so it stays down
here at the bottom of the keyboard for
quite a long time until we get up to
some very big numbers, before we actually
have to round them down.
(Why do you like that piece of music?)
Why do I like it? Well
it has that rhythm to it, it goes da da
da da da da
and those those repetitions are because
of the binary expansion.
And then every so often like at
powers of 2 minus 1
we get a bigger number.
And before it we get some other big
numbers, so there's a rhythm.
So the sound, the sounds,
reflect the structure of the binary
numbers;
but processed, it's not just the straight
binary numbers.
(Neil, as you keep planing the binaries,)
(obviously we were we were staying pretty)
(low there with those numbers,)
(do you start eventually getting some big)
(numbers when you
turn them into, you know,)
(base 10?)
Yeah certainly. When we got up to say 2
to the 20 minus 1,
plane off 1 we get nineteen 1s in a row,
so eventually we get all - does every
number appear? Yeah sure.
Okay so there's an inverse operation
which is extending all the runs by 1
bit
and that works for any number.
(What's that called? If that's-
if that's le raboter)
what do you call the other version?)
- I
just called it expanding.
Claude didn't mention it in his letter,
but obviously you could do it.
You expand all the runs by 1. And then
if you applied his operation
you'd get back to where you started, so
you can get every number.
So a question is, after you've planed
down a number
how big is it? What's the average value
after you plane it down? So I looked at
that and
I asked some friends for help and they
proved my conjecture is correct.
If n is k bits
long in binary, in other words if it's
a k-bit number.
So for instance here are all the three
bit numbers:
there are actually four of them. A three
bit number,
beginning with 1 of course, apart from
zero every
binary number begins with 1. So we
could have 1 0 0 all the way
up to 1 1 1.
So there are um 2 to the k minus 1
three bit numbers, there are two squared
numbers, there are four of them. What's
the average value?
Well it happens to be, we had four
numbers
whose sum is four so the average
value afterwards is 1.
So what happens for a k-bit number? I
conjectured
that the average value after is
exactly three halves to the power k minus
1 minus a half. And the way I found
that was I worked out the average,
you can see I just worked out the
average for 3-bit numbers and I got
1. If you do that for the first 20 or
terms you get a sequence. What you do
when you get a sequence? You look it up
in the OEIS.
And it is sequence A027649,
which is the integer three halves to the
k minus 1 minus a half.
So the answer to this question, how big
is what you get,
it's about three halves to the k.
So n was about 2 to the k and we
shrunk it down
to three halves to the k, so that's the
answer.
You might remember these pieces of pi
we shared with Numberphile
supporters a
while back?
Well they were so popular we've now
created these unique views
of our beloved Mandelbrot set. Each piece
is individually numbered and is a
one-off perspective;
a different location, a different
magnification. If you'd like us
to send you one,
find out more in the link we've included
below.
I want to talk about approximating pi in
the Mandelbrot set,
maybe it's best to do a little bit of a
reminder about what
the Mandelbrot set is?
So remember the Mandelbrot set was this
object that we have in the complex plane;
so here are the real numbers, and here
imaginary numbers. And the Mandelbrot set
was
a collection of complex numbers, so I'll
try and sort of draw a nice version of
this here...